et les discussions qui continueront
cette semaine avec une réunion possible
des dirigeants de l'ue eux ce jeudi mais
sur le terrain comment ce ballet
diplomatique est il perçu quelles sont
les attentes de la population dans le
donbass on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
antoine claireaux ados nièce bonsoir
antoine des têtes à têtes dont deux
dirigeants politiques loin du quotidien
des premières personnes concernées
finalement comment est vécue cette
séquence diplomatique sur place
oui bon ça se finit bien alors bien
entendu les gens d'ici ils en discutent
entre eux ils en parlent ils sont
courant de ce qui se passe mais pour la
plupart ce n'est qu'un énième
enchaînement de tractations
diplomatiques qui au final n'aura pas
d'impact réel sur leur vie quotidienne
du coup certains nous disent qu'ils
arrêtent tout bonnement de s'informer et
d'autres sont juste désabusé par la
situation actuelle comme par exemple
youri que nous avons rencontrées sur le
marché ce matin j'écoutais
personnellement j'essaie de ne pas
regarder la télévision
parce que je comprends que tout ce qu'on
nous raconte ne concerne que les
rencontres politiques des débats
politiques sans fin petite chose qui
obtient des boîtes voilà ils se sont
rencontrés ils ont parlé et alors où est
le résultat le résultat sera là quand il
n'y aura plus un seul coup de feu quand
il y aura de la stabilité économique et
la prospérité
quand la région se développera alors le
résultat sera là ou presque huit ans
après le début du conflit il y en a eu
des réunions de dirigeants des réunions
de diplomates mais le constat reste le
même pas ou peu d'améliorations pour la
vie quotidienne des gens ici dans le
donbass et antoine à la douma d'état en
russie certains avancent l'idée que
moscou reconnaisse les deux républiques
autoproclamées du dombass comment cette
nouvelle et elle accueilli sur place
oui à l'heure actuelle il ne s'agit que
d'une que d'une ébauche de texte qui
doit encore être envoyés à différents
ministères pour consultations n'ont donc
il n'ya donc encore rien de fait mais
pour les autorités locales ici dans le
donbass il s'agit en quelque sorte d'une
fausse boni d'une proposition qui sera
très difficile à mettre en place à
mettre en oeuvre ici dans le donbass
écoutez le monde
pourquoi parce que le processus de mise
autour duquel tout ce débat acharné se
déroule maintenant a bien été initiée
par la fédération de russie
c'est à l'initiative de la fédération de
russie qu'une résolution a été adoptée
au sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
sur la base de laquelle le conflit doit
être résolu pacifiquement et la
reconnaissance de cette territoire aussi
triste que ce soit pour moi permettra
l'ukraine à tous les pays du format
normandie de déclarer officiellement que
la russie a violé l'accord et par
conséquent les accords de must c'est ce
qu'on mettra plus qu'ils ne s'enlisent
mais comme on viens de l'entendre les
les autorités les responsables des
républiques autoproclamées de donetsk
mais aussi de lougansk sont très
attachés à l'application de ces accords
de minsk pour eux il s'agit du seul
document qui a été signé par toutes les
parties prenantes de cette crise quant à
la population elle veut juste des
résultats concrets elle veut enfin que
ces bombardements se termine et qu'elle
trouve enfin également des perspectives
d'avenir pour eux et pour leurs enfants
merci antoine gayraud en direct depuis
le dombass et 2